palais royal il est l'un des rares
artistes français à connaître une
carrière internationale
alors si vous aimez les rayures la
provocation et l'art contemporain je
vous invite dans il ne faut jurer de
rien a adopté la buren attitude
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat cette semaine la session
extraordinaire du parlement continue au
sein de la haute assemblée
cet après midi les sénateurs vont devoir
voter en procédure simplifiée diverses
conventions internationales avant
d'examiner le projet de loi organique
visant à proroger le mandat des membres
du conseil économique social et
environnemental
puis ils entameront la discussion
générale du projet de loi visant à
réduire la fracture numérique
voilà pour le programme de cet après
midi bonne séance à tous sur public
sénat l'ordre du jour appelle examen de
neuf projets de loi tendant à autoriser
l'approbation la ratification de
conventions internationales pour ses
neufs projet de loi la conférence des
présidents retenu la presse la procédure
simplifiée
je vais donc les maîtres successivement
voix je mets au voile article unique
constituant l'ensemble du projet de loi
autorisant l'approbation de la
convention entre le gouvernement de la
république française et le gouvernement
du royaume uni de grande bretagne et
d'irlande du nord en vue d'éviter les
doubles impositions et de prévenir
l'évasion et la fraude fiscale en
matière d'impôt sur le revenu sur les
gains en capital qui est pour adopter ce
projet de convention qui est contre le
projet de loi est adopté à l'unanimité
je me revois l'article me constituant
l'ensemble du projet de loi autorisant
l'approbation de l'avenant à la
convention entre le gouvernement de la
république française et le gouvernement
des états unis d'amérique en vue
d'éviter les doubles impositions et de
prévenir l'évasion et la fraude fiscales
hama en matière d'impôts sur le revenu
et sur la fortune pied pour qui et
contre le projet de loi est adopté je
mets au voile article unique constituant
l'ensemble du projet de autorisant
l'approbation de l'avenant à la
convention entre la france et la
belgique tendant à éviter les doubles
impositions et établir des règles
d'assistance administrative
riddick réciproque en matière d'impôts
sur les revenus qui est pour le projet
de loi est adopté je mets ouvre à
l'article ni constituant l'ensemble du
projet de l'autorisant la ratification
de l'accord entre l'irlande le royaume
des pays bas le royaume d'espagne la
république italienne la république
portugaise la république française et le
royaume uni de grande bretagne et
d'irlande du nord
établissant un centre opérationnel
d'analysé du renseignement maritime pour
les stupéfiants qui et pour qui et
contre le projet de loi est adopté je
mets ce voile article unique constituant
l'ensemble du projet de loi autorisant
l'approbation de la convention de
partenariat entre le gouvernement de la
république française et le gouvernement
de la république algérienne démocratique
et populaire qu'est pour qui et contre
le projet de loi est adopté je me vois
l'article unique constituant l'ensemble
du projet de loi autorisant
l'approbation du protocole relatif à la
gestion intégrée des zones côtières de
la méditerranée qui est pour et qui est
contre est adopté je me vois l'article
unis constituent un ensemble du projet
de l'autorisant l'approbation de
l'accord entre le gouvernement de la
république française et le conseil des
miss de la république d'albanie relatif
à la coopération en matière de sécurité
intérieure qui époux qui est contre le
projet de loi est adopté je me revois
l'article unique constituant l'ensemble
du projet de loi autorisant
l'approbation de l'accord sous forme
d'échangé de lettres entre le
gouvernement de la république française
et le gouvernement la république
italienne visant à compléter l'accord
relatif à la coopération
transfrontalière en matière policière et
douanière qui et pour qui et contre le
projet de loi est adopté
enfin je me revois l'article unis
constituent à l'ensemble du projet de
loi adopté par l'assemblée nationale
autorisant l'approbation de la
convention entre le gouvernement de la
république française et l'organisation
internationale de la francophonie
relative à la mise à disposition de
locaux pour installer la maison de la
francophonie à paris qui est pour et qui
est contre le projet de loi est
définitivement adopté l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion du projet de loi
organique adoptée par l'assemblée
nationale après engagement de la
procédure accélérée ont rejoint le
mandat des membres du conseil économique
social et environnemental dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur henri de raincourt ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
vous avez la parole monsieur 2010
monsieur le président
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs dans le cadre de
la modernisation de nos institutions
la loi constitutionnelle du 23 juillet
2008 à transformer le conseil économique
et social en conseil économique social
et environnemental
elle a étendu sa compétence consultative
aux questions environnementales
avec le grenelle lui mais non c'est une
des traductions de la volonté du
président de la république de placer
l'écologie et le développement durable
au coeur de nos préoccupations et de nos
débats la revalorisation du conseil
économique et social souhaité par le
constituant a également pris la forme
d'une modification des coq des
conditions de sa saisine et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs à l'initiative
de votre haute assemblée
la constitution donne désormais la
possibilité au parlement de consulter le
conseil prérogatives réservé depuis 1958
au gouvernement les citoyens pourront
eux-mêmes saisir le conseil par voie de
pétition
celui ci fera connaître au gouvernement
et au parlement
les suites qu'il propose de donner à
chaque saisine citoyenne la mise en
oeuvre de cette réforme impose une
profonde modification de l'ordonnancé du
29 décembre 1958 portant loi organique
relative au conseil économique et social
la procédure des saisines parlementaire
devra être précisé les conditions
d'exercice du droit de pétition devant
être défini plus globalement le
fonctionnement du conseil économique
social et environnemental devra être
adapté comme l'a parfaitement
après votre collègue monsieur jean
claude frécon dans le rapport qu'il a
fait au nom de la commission des
finances
mais la tâche la plus délicate sera
l'adaptation de la composition du
conseil économique social et
environnemental
en effet celle-ci n'a connu depuis 1958
que de très faibles ajustements pour le
gouvernement il est indispensable que
les différentes composantes de la
société civile contemporaine trouvent
aujourd'hui leur place au sein de ce
conseil
rénové par ailleurs la nouvelle
compétence environnementale devra se
traduire dans la composition même du
conseil elle implique l'entrée de
représentants des associations de
protection de l'environnement
cette double modification de la
composition du conseil économique social
et environnemental doit être réalisée à
effectif constant
en effet je rappelle que la révision
constitutionnelle de juillet 2008 a fixé
le nombre des membres à 2 133 soit celui
qui est actuellement prévu
le principe ainsi posée est d'ailleurs
le même que celui qui a été retenu pour
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
tout risque d'accroissement important du
nombre de conseillers et de ce fait
écartée mais la réforme de la
composition du conseil se révèle
d'autant plus une tâche complexe au mois
de novembre 2008 le président de la
république a confié à monsieur dominique
jean chertier directeur du pôle emploi
est lui-même membre du conseil
économique social et environnemental le
soin de réaliser un rapport sur la mise
en oeuvre des nouvelles missions de ce
conseil et la rénovation de sa
composition
il a remis son rapport le 15 janvier
dernier et il propose plusieurs
principe d'évolution de la composition
quel que soit le choix qui sera fait
toute modification appellera des efforts
de la part des groupes actuellement
présents au sein du conseil économique
social et environnemental en termes
d'effectifs sans tôt la nouvelle
physionomie peut-être d'ores et déjà
esquissé le nouveau conseil devrait être
constituée autour de trois grands pôles
significatif la vie économique et le
dialogue social
en deuxième lieu la cohésion sociale et
territoriale et la vie associative
enfin l'environnement et la protection
de la nature
les associations verront donc comme je
l'indiquais leur présence renforcée les
secteurs de l'économie solidaire de la
lutte contre l'exclusion du handicap du
sport les mondes de la science et de la
culture devrait trouver une
représentation au sein de ce conseil
enfin le rajeunissement et la
féminisation de l'institution devront
être poursuivis les jeunes et les
étudiants bénéficieront à ce titre d'une
représentation spécifique
la question de la représentativité est
un enjeu fondamental de cette rénovation
elle se posera avec acuité pour
l'ensemble des nouvelles composantes du
conseil notamment pour les organisations
de protection de l'environnement
le comité opérationnel du grenelle de
l'environnement dirigé par monsieur
bertrand pancher député de la meuse et
auquel ont participé vos collègues
pierre jarlier épaulera hoult a déjà
travaillé sur la question de la
représentativité des acteurs
environnementaux
la désignation de ces acteurs devra se
faire sur la base de critères très
précis
la discussion sur ces critères aura lieu
dans le cadre de l'examen du projet de
loi grenelle 2 qui viendra en première
lecture au sénat dès la rentrée
parlementaire
par ailleurs monsieur jean pierre vial a
eu tout à fait raison de souligner dans
son excellent rapport qu'il sera aussi
nécessaire de préserver les équilibres
de représentation existantes
actuellement au sein du conseil
économique social et environnemental
ainsi la pratique de la concertation et
la recherche permanente du consensus
pourront et devront demeurer un atout
essentiel du conseil
l'ensemble de ces exigences à remplir
montre que cette réforme s'avère
délicate tant dans les grands choix à
opérer que dans des modalités très
concrète de sa mise en oeuvre
le temps de l'analyse et de la
concertation est pour le gouvernement
une condition essentielle du succès de
cette réforme
par ailleurs cette réforme de grande
envergure vient prendre place dans le
vaste chantier législatif ouvert par la
révision constitutionnelle le temps et
l'énergie nécessaires sont consacrés par
le gouvernement à construire dans le
dialogue
une véritable réforme du conseil
économique social et environnemental
le projet de loi organique ne pourra en
conséquence être adopté définitivement
par le parlement
soumis à l'examen du conseil
constitutionnel est promulguée par le
président de la république avant la fin
du mandat des membres actuels du conseil
en septembre 2009 le renouvellement des
membres en septembre 2009 sur le
demandez lise position actuelle
conduirait à reporter les effets de
cette réforme au prochain renouvellement
en 2014 et une telle situation
un tel calendrier n'est pas pour le
gouvernement souhaitable il ne serait
pas davantage satisfaisant que l'entrée
en vigueur de la loi organique modifiant
la composition du conseil mette fin au
mandat des membres ainsi nommé au mois
de septembre la procédure lourde de
renouvellement devrait alors être mises
en oeuvre à deux reprises séparer de
quelques mois seulement
le gouvernement propose donc à votre
haute assemblée de proroger le mandat
des membres actuels du conseil
économique social et environnemental
jusqu'à la mise en oeuvre de la réforme
vous le savez une telle solution a déjà
été utilisée à plusieurs reprises tant
pour les assemblées élues que pour des
conseils économiques et sociaux
régionaux
la prorogation devrait s'appliquer
jusqu'au terme d'un délai de 4 mois
suivant la publication de la loi
organique
en effet ce délai est nécessaire pour
assurer la modification des textes
réglementaires et la désignation des
nouveaux membres par les organisations
qui représenteront qui seront
représentés au conseil un délai butoir
est enfin prévu afin de conserver à la
disposition qui vous est proposé un
caractère transitoire qui soient
raisonnables et la prorogation ne pourra
en tout état de cause
excédé le 30 septembre 2010 la réforme
devra donc est adoptée au cours de la
séance de la session 2
1009 2010 voilà ce que je souhaitais
vous présenter au nom du gouvernement et
en vous indiquant que le projet de loi
et organiques qui réformera le conseil
économique social et environnemental
sera déposé au parlement dès la
prochaine rentrée parlementaire
c'est à dire très prochainement merci je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur jean pierre
vial rapporteur de la commission des
lois
j'ai président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues notre assemblée ce truc
saisi du projet de loi organique relatif
à la prorogation du mandat des membres
du conseil économique et social devenu
conseil économique social et
environnemental
aux termes de la réforme
constitutionnelle du 23 juillet 2008
l'enjeu réside bien dans la révision
constitutionnelle de juillet 2008 qui a
largement modifié les attributions le
fonctionnement et la composition du
conseil économique et social
il s'agit là d'une nouvelle étape dans
la vie du conseil économique et social
institution originale qui l'a conduit
être qualifié de troisième chambre en
même temps que d'autres pouvaient
s'interroger sur son rôle
créé en 1925 sous le nom de conseil
national économique
c'était en réalité qu'en 1946 et 1958
que le conseil économique et social se
voit confirmé comme une institution à
part entière reconnu par la constitution
de 1946 est confirmée par la
constitution de 1958 avec un titre
spécifique
la présente réforme constitutionnelle ne
se réduit pas à un simple aspect formel
mais se rattachent à cette volonté
politique qui veut faire du conseil
économique et social un acteur à part
entière du débat démocratique
aux côtés du parlement pourquoi ne pas
souligner à quel point dès la libération
le général de gaulle considéré comme
nécessaire l'expression de la société
civile à travers sa composante
économique et social dont l'idée d'un
grand sénart 1958 et du projet
référendaire de 1969 était une
traduction forte quand bien même
fut-elle rejeté par trois fois cette
nécessité de trouver les moyens
d'associer les acteurs de la société
civile
au coeur du débat politique a gardé
toute son actualité
si certains grands pays voisins comme
l'allemagne l'angleterre sont dépourvus
d'une telle institution
encore convient-il de souligner que
l'acceptation direct sociale dans ces
pays résulte d'un processus
d'élaboration tout particulièrement
ancré dans leur culture politique et
sociale al'inverse un nombre beaucoup
plus important de pays ont suivi
l'exemple france
et en se dotant d'une telle institution
associant les acteurs de la société
civile à l'élaboration des choix
politiques l'enjeu repose donc bien sûr
l'émission le fonctionnement et la
représentation de l'institution dont
aujourd'hui presque trois quarts de son
activité relève de sa propre auto
saisine la réforme constitutionnelle de
donc répondre à ce triple défi c'est
d'abord l'élargissement du champ de
compétence du conseil économique et
social en l'étendant aux questions
environnementales
à ce sujet si la saisine du conseil dans
les domaines de l'environnement reste
facultative tout projet de programmation
à caractère environnemental devra lui
être soumis pour avis comme pour ceux à
caractère économique et social
c'est ensuite le double élargissement de
la saisine du conseil saisine au
bénéfice du parlement
conformément à la nouvelle rédaction de
l'article 70 de la constitution adopté
sur proposition du sénat saisine au
bénéfice des citoyens par voie de
pétition dont la loi organique aura à
préciser les conditions
c'est enfin la rénovation de
l'institution par une nouvelle
composition qui devra intégrer la
limitation des membres à 233 nombreux
fixée par la constitution à l'instar du
nombre des membres des deux assemblées
parlementaires
il s'agit en réalité d'une double
réforme à celle du réajustement des
différentes catégories de ses membres
pour une meilleure représentation de la
société
attendue depuis longtemps s'y ajoute
l'intégration des nouveaux membres de la
représentation environnementale tous les
aspects de la réforme auraient pu se
mettre en oeuvre sans une remise en
cause du calendrier électoral du
renouvellement dément en revanche la
révision de la composition du conseil
nécessite une rénovation en profondeur
de la représentation et constitue un
élément majeur de la réforme concernant
la prise en compte la plus large
possible des différentes composantes de
la société civile
la question a été posée par certains
sur la représentation éventuelle des
cultes je tiens à dire que j'étais
sensible monsieur le ministre à la
position que vous avez exprimées à
l'assemblée nationale en soulignant que
le gouvernement n'y était pas favorable
et que cette représentation ne serait
donc pas proposer dans la loi organique
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre de
bien vouloir me le confirmer à l'issue
de ces débats
le rapport de dominique jean chertier
remis au président de la république
montre bien à travers les trois
scénarios proposés
l'enjeu fondamental que représente la
réforme de la composition du conseil
dont l'absence d'ajustement progressive
avait amené un véritable décalage entre
l'expression de l'institution et sa
représentation qu'ils pouvaient en être
fortement discutée à défaut d'être
abordée avec courage car tu es cette
question de la représentativité aurait
posé immanquablement de plus en plus
fortement sur la légitimité de
l'institution compte tenu de l' objet
très limitée du texte il n'y a pas lieu
de se prononcer aujourd'hui sur la
composition du futur conseil
néanmoins il me semble utile de
souligner dès à présent que la force du
conseil est d'être un lieu d' expertise
sociale où s'élaborent des consensus
entre les différents acteurs de la
société civile et de la vie
professionnelle
il faudra en tenir compte pour désigner
les nouveaux membres
intégré au conseil en particulier les
acteurs de l'environnement
la réforme portant sur la composition
est donc un enjeu essentiel dont le
temps nécessaire à la concertation doit
être une des conditions de succès encore
convient-il que cette étape de
concertation se trouve précisément
encadrée dans un délai raisonnable le
report de l'échéance un délai de 4 mois
suivant la promulgation de la loi avec
une date butoir fixée au 30 septembre
2010 constitue sur ce point de vue ce
délai raisonnable du report du
renouvellement des membres du conseil
économique et social et environnemental
conformément à la position de la
commission des lois
je vous remercie donc mes chers
collègues de bien vouloir adopter ce
projet par un vote conforme au texte
adopté par l'assemblée nationale
qui lui a apporté les modifications
rédactionnelle nécessaire je vous en
remercie je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur dans le sud la discussion
générale la parole et à madame anne
marie escoffier
ce président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues héritier du conseil
national économique est créée en 1925
convient de leur rappeler notre
accédants rapporteur à la demande des
syndicats ouvriers des principaux
acteurs de la vie économique de l'état
et de l'époque puis supprimé par le
régime de vichy
le conseil économique rétabli en 1946
devenu en 1958 conseil économique et
social et en 2008 conseil économique et
social environnemental est une
institution essentielle dans la vie de
la nation
ces appréciations publication remarque
avis ou conseillent toujours marquées du
double sceau de la compétence et du
sérieux sont très largement apprécié
nous ne saurions du reste oublier que le
comité économique et social constitue la
troisième assemblée constitutionnelle
avec l'assemblée nationale le sénat
un certain projet constitutionnel
développé par le général de gaulle ni à
une quarantaine d'années était même allé
jusqu'à suggérer que sénateur et
conseillers économiques et sociaux us qu
siégé de conserve dans une structure
commune
c'est dire l'intérêt que présente non
pas tant ce projet de loi organique
prorogeant le mandat de ses membres que
nous étudions aujourd'hui que le projet
de loi organique à venir modernisant et
valorisant le conseil économique social
et environnemental
ce futur projet de loi est la
conséquence de la révision
constitutionnelle de juillet 2008 qui
lui permettra entre autres d'une part
d'élargir ses missions aux questions
environnementales
d'autre part de fixer les conditions de
sa saisine au parlement et de mettre en
oeuvre le nouveau principe de jets
saisine sur pétition citoyenne au
préalable une remarque s'impose alors
que le gouvernement a mis en oeuvre il
ya tout juste un an cette réforme
constitutionnelle en sachant qu'à
l'aller
inévitablement entraîner la réforme du
conseil économique et social
environnemental
on peut s'interroger sur les raisons du
retard apporté à ce projet de loi
monsieur le ministre pourquoi un tel
silence sur un texte dont on ne sait
toujours pas à quelle date il sera
présenté au parlement mais vous venez de
nous donner une échéance et je vous en
remercie
même s'il semble qu'il soit actuellement
soumis à l'examen du conseil d'état
cette manière de gouverner par là même
de légiférer qui consiste à attendre
lorsqu'il y a sinon urgence du moins des
limites de temps à respecter cette
habitude regrettable prise de multiplier
les lois transitoire plutôt que d'être
prêt à honorer les rendez vous
législatifs prévus au cas particulier
depuis 12 mois ne manque pas d'être
critiquable et nous les donnons sont
chaque fois
cette remarque monsieur le ministre vous
savez ne s'adresse pas à vous
personnellement mais je suis certaine
que vous en comprendrez le sens puisque
en tant que sénateur vous avez passé de
nombreuses années dans cet hémicycle à
défendre les prérogatives parlementaires
je ne doute pas qu'en haut lieu vous
serez faire part de cette remarque
le présent projet de loi doté d'un
article unique propose d'adopter une
disposition transitoire afin de
préserver le fonctionnement du conseil
dans la tente de l'adoption de la loi
organique est de savoir proroger d'une
année le mandat de ses membres jusqu'au
30 septembre 2010 au plus tard il s'agit
de ce fait d'un texte consensuel que
nous ne pouvons qu'approuver dans sa
forme ce que fera le groupe rds ceux qui
mesurent parfaitement qu'il serait
dommageable pour la communauté nationale
que soit interrompu les travaux du
conseil économique social et
environnemental
ce texte de surcroît nous donne
l'occasion d'évoquer la future loi
organique dont l'objectif de lady et de
modernisme
et et de valoriser une institution qui a
besoin d'évaluer d'évoluer sans pour
autant que soient dénaturés l'outil
lequel représente et qui a pour vocation
de favoriser le dialogue la coopération
et les échanges d'expériences avec les
conseils économiques et sociaux
régionaux
le conseil économique et social européen
et les institutions similaires
étrangères une loi qui en intégrant le
qualificatif d' environnementale
désormais ajouter au traditionnel
conseil économique et social montre par
là même l'évidente légitimité que
constitue la lutte contre toutes les
formes de pollution et la recherche d'un
équilibre indispensable à la survie de
notre planète et de ses habitants
il reviendra d'ailleurs sur ce point au
prochain grenelle 2 de l'environnement
de fixer les critères de
représentativité de ce tiers secteur qui
vient compléter la représentativité des
organisations syndicales et celle des
organisations patronales l'essentiel
restera de ne pas remettre en cause les
grands équilibres actuels afin de ne pas
casser ce lieu de démocratie sociale
participative auquel on a abouti
aujourd'hui en favorisant toujours
l'expression de propositions partagées
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
rapporteur
je mesure bien sûr la difficulté de
trouver à ces équilibres au sein d'un
conseil dont le numerus clausus a été
opportunément limitée à 2 133 mhz et où
chaque secteur entend bien préserver ses
prérogatives au détriment des
nécessaires évolutions la
représentativité des entreprises
publiques ne devrait-elle pas par
exemple être réduite à moins de 10 alors
que celle des professions libérales
devrait aller au delà des trois sièges
qui lui sont actuellement au troyer je
ne doute pas que le problème de la
parité fera lui aussi question dans ce
débat faut-il imposer
lorsque le constat est celui d'un
pourcentage de 20% ou à peine plus
environ deux femmes ne faut-il pas aussi
à genève une assemblée dont la moyenne
d'âge graduellement augmente de 55 ans
et anvers 60 ans en imposant au sein de
chaque groupe une forme de quotas de
jeunes ne serait-il pas également
nécessaire de porter une réflexion sur
la limitation à deux du nombre des
mandats pour les futurs conseillers
autant de questions ouvertes qui
viennent s'inscrire à côté des mesures
opportunément prise s'agissant de la
saisine du parlement sous réserve du
contrôle des conditions de saisine ou de
la saisine sur pétition citoyenne dont
il conviendra de définir le seuil de
signataires sur tous ces points je ne
puis donc souhaité qu'à l'avenir le
conseil économique social et
environnemental soit performant gérer et
gérer de façon plus démocratique
appelé à devenir non pas une assemblée
des experts de la société civile mais de
l'assemblée des organisations composant
la société civile le conseil économique
social et environnemental pourra alors
pleinement remplir sa vocation
d'assemblée consultative favorisant la
collaboration entre les différentes
catégories professionnelles suggérant
les adaptations économique et social
indispensable contribuant à
l'information des assemblées
parlementaires
nous ne pouvons que nous en réjouir
c'est pourquoi le groupe rdse votera ce
texte et demeurera très attentif à la
rédaction du projet du prochain texte de
loi je vous remercie chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur richard yung
pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président mais c'est le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est la
loi constitutionnelle de juillet 2008
qui modernise est nos institutions qui a
élargi le champ de compétences du
conseil économique et social aux
questions environnementales conseiller
économique devenue d'ailleurs
entre-temps conseil économique et social
et en grande mental je rappelle que
cette disposition reprend une demande
formulée lors du grenelle de
l'environnement est reprise par le
comité balladur de proposition sur la
modernisation des institutions de la
république
l'élargissement du champ d'action du
conseil nécessitera bien sûr une
modification de sa composition
celle ci en effet ne reflète plus la
réalité de la société française
contemporaine
les femmes qui sont largement
minoritaires et ça c'est un crime
suprême
l'agriculture y est sur-représentée ses
classiques en france par tous les jeunes
et les étudiants en sont quasiment
absents et les personnalités qualifiées
nommées par le premier ministre sont on
pourrait dire très nombreuses saisies
soline très il est donc urgent de revoir
cette représentativité
la loi constitutionnelle a plafonné à 2
133 le nombre de conseillers
l'élargissement de la représentation
au milieu écologique implique donc une
reconfiguration des dix-huit groupes qui
composent le conseil
la tâche ne sera pas aisée l'histoire
montre en effet que la réforme de cette
assemblée du conseil économique social
et environnemental peut s'avérer
difficile il suffit de rappeler l'échec
du référendum de 1969 et par ailleurs
nous savons par expérience que modifier
la composition d'une assemblée à
effectif constant nous avons fait
l'exercice
il n'y a pas longtemps pour ce qui
concerne l'assemblée nationale est
toujours un exercice difficile et
douloureux l'article 71 de la
constitution dispose que la composition
du cso est fixé par une loi organique
un an après la réforme constitutionnelle
je constate avec d'autres que vous
n'avez toujours pas présenté ce texte
devant le parlement
vous avez considéré qu'il était plus
urgent de faire adopter
beaucoup d'autres textes et nous
connaissons les aléas de l'agenda
parlementaire
par exemple le texte tendant à faciliter
le retour au parlement des membres du
gouvernement qui certainement avait
priorité
cette situation est d'autant plus
regrettable que le rapport de dominique
chertier sur la réforme des crs a été
remise au président de la république le
15 janvier c'est à dire il y a un peu
plus de six mois pour justifier le
retard vous avancer l'argument selon
laquelle la désignation des acteurs et
des conseillers environnementaux devra
se faire sur la base de critères de
représentativité qui seront fixées par
la future loi portant engagement
national pour l'environnement 5 monde
appelle grenelle 2 vous nous avez
indiqué que le projet de loi organique
sera déposé au parlement dès les tout
premiers jours de la rentrée
je vous remercie de cette précision dont
acte et sachez donc que nous serons
vigilants quant à son inscription sur le
l'agenda parlementaire qui sera sans
doute assez assez serré à la rentrée au
lieu de désigner même provisoirement les
nouveaux membres du cs sur la base des
règles actuellement en vigueur
vous avez estimé mais j'ai plus de
ministres là je continue à pardon
excusez moi mal à toutes mes excuses
il ya toujours un nom mais dont je
pensais à notre ancien collègue vous
avez estimé
bon ne pensait pas le poignard nord
français pas le poignard vous avez
estimé qu'il était plus efficient de
prolonger le mandat des membres actuels
jusqu'à après le vote et l'entrée en
vigueur de la réforme
en fixant une date butoir au 30
septembre 2010
cette disposition n'appelle pas de
commentaire particulier de notre part
j'espère nous espérons qu'elle permettra
que les délais supplémentaires ainsi
données permettront de créer du
consensus
c'est quelque chose dont on a besoin en
france et je suivrai donc les
recommandations de notre excellent
rapporteur prend la matière et je
profite de l'occasion pour formuler
quelques remarques concernant la future
réforme de la composition du cms e
puisque les propositions vont donc venir
maintenant très rapidement monsieur
chertier donc qui avait été chargé d'un
rapport de propositions propose de faire
entrer dans ce conseil renouvelé des
représentants des jeunes et des
associations oeuvrant dans le domaine de
l'écologie et du développement durable
et il envisage trois scénarios un
ajustement périodique qui permette
l'adaptation de façon continue du de la
composition du csm
un second scénario un peu plus radicale
qui vise à faire du cv ce une assemblée
des experts de la société civile avec
trois groupes à peu près égaux
employeurs salariés
les associations et un groupe d'experts
qui serait un peu plus grand et enfin
troisième scénario la transformation du
cnse en assemblée de corps
intermédiaires représentatif des corps
intermédiaires syndicats employeurs
associations ces quelques doutes sur le
troisième scénario qui a en quelque
sorte un parfum un peu corporatiste et
qui rappellent des philosophies d'un
temps que je considère que nous
considérons comme passé donc nous aurons
sans doute plus à nous concentrer sur
les deux premiers scénarios pour ma part
je voudrais souligner 3,3 élément
important pour nous en tout cas la
nécessité de garder une représentation
substantielle et égale des collèges
représentant les employeurs et les
salariés
le cse est en effet un des rares
endroits en france où il y ait
effectivement un débat entre les
représentants des salariés et des
employeurs entre ces deux classes
j'allais dire classes sociales mais vous
allez me taxer de marxisme alors ces
deux catégories
oui on peut ces deux catégories sociales
et vous savez que notre pays souffre
notre vieux pays gallo-romain souffle de
donner toujours la préférence à
l'affrontement à la guérilla frontalière
et a considéré que l'accord et le
consensus ne sont pas ne sont pas de
mise ce qui est pas le cas dans beaucoup
d'autres pays est donc le conseil
économique et social à nos yeux apporte
beaucoup par ce dialogue permanent qui
est entretenue entre ces deux grandes
ces deux grandes catégories de
représentants d'ong premiers éléments
deuxième élément la nécessité et s'est
dit dans le texte de définir des
critères de représentativité
consensuelle et indiscutable pour le
choix des représentants des milieux de
l'environnement et de l'ocs l'écologie
en effet les milieux les associations et
les milieux qui s'intéressent à ces
questions là sont extrêmement divers
certains s'intéressent à l'énergie
d'autres s'intéressent aux transports
d'autres à l'agriculture biologique
certaines sur des trois grandes
associations internationales d'autres
sont au contraire très petit il y a donc
une foultitude avec de grandes
différences dans dans ces milieux et
donc le choix des représentants des
parle de 18 ou 20 représentants c'était
le choix sera quelque chose de difficile
même s'ils seront pris comme on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure sur le quota des
entreprises publiques ou de
l'agriculture
il faudra donc beaucoup de sagesse dans
le choix de ses représentants
enfin permettez euros aux sénateurs
représentant les français de l'étranger
de souhaiter que la représentation des
français à l'étranger
il y en a deux soit maintenu dans la
nouvelle configuration
je ne dis pas ça je ne dis pas ça par
corporatisme
quoique quoique il y est quand même à
l'arrière pensée et les arrière pensées
vous savez comme moi c'est ce qui est
pire à l'arrière pensée de la réforme
qui a introduit les députés l'idée qu'il
n'ya plus besoin de représentants des
français à l'étranger au conseil
économique et social ici quelque chose
contre lequel et je pense avec mes
collègues
dans le cas de l'union sacrée nous nous
élevons voilà et moi je proposerai pour
que les choses soient bien claires parce
que c'est important qu'il y ait de tels
représentants qu'il soit non plus nommé
par le gouvernent
le mans mais désigné par chacune des
deux grandes organisations
représentatives des français à
l'étranger à savoir l'ufe et l'adf
dans une lettre qu'il m'a adressées il
m'écrit voyez le 19 mai dernier le
premier ministre a indiqué que la
réforme du conseil économique social et
environnemental est en préparation je
souhaite donc savoir madame la ministre
quelles sont les conclusions que le
gouvernement tire de la publication du
rapport cherti qu'en est-il par exemple
de la représentation des cultes au nom
de la laïcité ne s'est certes y est et
les membres du comité balladur avait
refusé les forces spirituelles soient
représentés à l'assemblée nationale le
gouvernement a indiqué qu' il n'y était
pas non plus favorable qu'il ne le
proposerait pas ces propos sont pleins
de bon sens mais il faut en même temps
en contradiction avec les déclarations
du président de la république qui en
décembre 2007 avait exprimé son souhait
d'élargir la représentation du conseil
aux représentants des grands courants
spirituels
donc j'imagine les églises mais aussi
les grandes les grandes écoles
philosophiques mais elles sont l est où
va-t-on et sachant quel est le poids de
l'elysée dans notre vie politique
je suis donc moyennement rassurés par
ces propos je voulais aussi savoir si
l'armée serait représente andré en tant
que tel c'était une idée qui avait été
avancée
et enfin je souhaitais vous interroger
sur l'élargissement des saisines c'est
un des points importants 1 des progrès
le ser et ce ne sera plus seulement le
conseil de l'exécutif il sera il y aura
la possibilité pour le parlement pour
nous au sénat de consulter ce conseil
sur les questions économiques et
sociales et ça sera une excellente chose
puisque nous
ont besoin d'une capacité d'expertisé et
il y aura aussi le nom route le nouveau
droit de pétition citoyenne sur ces deux
dispositions ce souhaiterais savoir
comment leur mise en oeuvre est prévue
selon quelles modalités
dans le nouveau projet de loi organique
voilà mes chers collègues les
principales remarques ce que nous
souhaitions faire sur la réforme à venir
en réitérant donc le fait nous voterons
la mesure transitoire le permettant de
prolonger la durée du mandat des
conseillers en cours merci je merci
chers collègues la parole et à madame
eliane assassi le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la réforme
du conseil économique et social a été
donc souhaité annoncer dès juillet 2007
par le président de la république date à
laquelle il a chargé edouard balladur
président du comité de réflexion sur les
institutions de la vème république
d'intégrer cette question dans les
travaux du comité
le principal enjeu était alors
d'intégrer la problématique du
développement durable et de
l'environnement aux thèmes traités par
le conseil économique et social ce dont
nous nous félicitons la révision
constitutionnelle de juillet 2008 a
ainsi ouvert la voie à une réforme
d'ampleur du conseil économique et
social dont devenu donc conseil
économique social et environnemental ce
qui nécessite une révision tout aussi
conséquente des dispositions organique
relative au conseil
il s'avère et cela déjà été dit que le
calendrier nécessaire à cette révision
des dispositions organiques ne coïncide
pas avec la durée du mandat de celles et
ceux qui en sont actuellement membres
le gouvernement n'ayant pas encore
présenté au parlement de loi organique
la réforme du conseil ne pourra donc pas
intervenir avant la fin du mandat en
cours de ses membres qui expire en
septembre 2009 une solution a dû être
trouvée ici pourquoi nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui
la révision constitutionnelle a tout
d'abord élargi les compétences du
conseil aux questions environnementales
il devra donc intégrer de nouveaux
membres issus d'associations
environnementales et sur ce point se
posera la question de la
représentativité et des critères qui
devront être retenu pour la désignation
de ces nouveaux membres
la révision constitutionnelle a
également ouvert la possibilité au
parlement de consulter le conseil sur
tout problème de caractère économique
social ou environnemental possibilité
qui est jusqu'à présent réservé au
gouvernement et donc le conseil peut
également se saisir lui-même de toute
question relevant de sa compétence enfin
la révision constitutionnelle a créé une
possibilité de saisine du conseil
ouverte aux citoyens par voie de
pétition donc une loi organique est
nécessaire pour modifier les missions et
les attributions du cs ainsi que sa
composition son organisation et son
fonctionnement
aujourd'hui déterminé par l' ordonnance
du 29 décembre 1958 il noie organique
est également nécessaire pour l'entrée
en vigueur de la nouvelle rédaction de
l'article 69 de la constitution
permettant la saisine du csm par voie de
pétition
si en revanche la saisine par le
parlement ne nécessite pas une loi
organique le gouvernement a néanmoins
décidé d'inclure cette question dans la
future loi organique
l' ordonnance du 29 décembre 58
prévoyant en effet les modalités de
saisine par le gouvernement alors compte
tenu de l'ampleur de la réforme le
gouvernement n'a pas été en mesure de
nous présenter un projet de loi
organique avant je l' ai déjà dit que
n'expire le mandat des membres actuels
du cs est pourtant un travail important
de réflexion sur cette réforme a déjà
été produit
bernard planchais député s'est vu
confier en février 2008 par le premier
ministre la présidence d'un comité
opérationnel chargé de mettre en oeuvre
des conclusions du grenelle de
l'environnement et ce travail a abouti à
des propositions précises pour permettre
une sélection à l'aide de critères de
représentativité et d'éligibilité des
acteurs représentatifs du secteur
environnemental
ce travail a été ensuite complété par la
révision constitutionnelle par un
travail préparatoire 2
la réforme plus globale du cs convié
confié donc en novembre 2008 par le
président de la république a à dominique
jean chertier est destinée à préparer la
mise en oeuvre des nouvelles missions du
cso son rapport a été remis à monsieur
le président de la république le 15
janvier 2009
enfin notre collègue jean paul jean
claude frécon à a présenté un rapport
d'information le 6 mai sur cette réforme
donc suite à l'ensemble de ces travaux
de réflexion je pense qu'il est
regrettable que nous ne connaissons même
pas les grandes lignes du projet de loi
organique à venir et fort de ce constat
le gouvernement avait donc trois
possibilités pour mettre en oeuvre la
réforme du cs la première les membres du
conseil aurait pu être renouvelé en
septembre 2009 sur le fondement du texte
actuellement en vigueur l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi organique modifiant sa
composition étant reportées au
renouvellement suivant c'est-à-dire en
2014 cette solution reporterait l'entrée
en vigueur de la réforme six ans après
l'arrêt mais la révision
constitutionnelle
deuxième possibilité les membres du
conseil aurait pu être renouvelé en
septembre 2009 sur le fondement du texte
actuellement huit en vigueur la loi
organique modifiant sa composition mais
enfin à leur mandat
à son entrée en vigueur pour procéder à
un nouveau renouvellement sur la base du
nouveau texte
c'est cette solution conduirait à nommer
de nouveaux membres pour quelques mois
seulement
troisième possibilité enfin une loi
organique viendrait donc prolonger le
mandat de ses membres actuels du cis
jusqu'à jusqu'après le vote et l'entrée
en vigueur de la réforme avec une date
butoir
cela nous a été redit tout à l'heure que
le gouvernement propose donc de fixer au
30 septembre 2010 donc les deux
premières solutions et en ayant été
jugée insatisfaisante par le
gouvernement c'est donc la troisième et
donc la prorogation du mandat des
membres actuels du conseil qui a été
choisi nous ne pouvons émettre
d'objection particulière sur cette
solution qui semble effectivement la
plus logique c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons pour lesquelles nous voterons ce
texte
néanmoins nous resterons vigilants sur
un certain nombre d'aspects notamment
s'agissant des contours de la figure la
future loi organique
en effet il est prévu d'intégrer de
nouveaux membres
entre 30 et 40 nous dit-on acteurs du
secteur environnemental mais léman le
nombre des membres du conseil fixé à 2
133 par la constitution restera fixe si
à l'assemblée nationale lors de l'examen
du texte le 1er juillet dernier
monsieur de raincourt avait dit
s'orienter vers une légère diminution
des représentants de la profession
agricole et de ceux des entreprises
publiques
le nombre d'entreprises publiques ayant
considère considérablement diminué pour
reprendre ses propos d'autres
modifications pouvant intervenir à
l'avenir ne sont pas exclus alors nous
serons particulièrement attentifs à une
éventuelle diminution du nombre des
représentants des salariés comme nous le
serons sur une nécessaire pressent
présence de jeunes en son sein et bien
évidemment le respect de la parité
hommes femmes
nous serons également attentif à
l'engagement du gouvernement sur le fait
de ne pas inclure dans la future loi
organique la possibilité pour des
représentants des cultes de siéger au
sein du conseil économique social et
environnemental
étant donné cela a été déjà dit que le
président de la république s'y est
déclaré pour sa part favorable
nous ne saurions guère étonné s'il
arrivait à faire céder le gouvernement
sur son coin je rappelle quand même que
la pratique d'un culte relève de la
sphère uniquement privé et nous ne
comprendrions pas qu'elle soit
institutionnalisée au sein du
institutionnalisée pardon au sein du
conseil économique social et
environnemental
donc nous espérons que la loi organique
sera présenté au parlement dans les
délais les plus brefs où nous allier à
l'automne
en attendant comme je l'indiqué nous
voterons ce projet de loi je remercie je
remercie chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean claude
frécon vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le projet de loi
organique soumis à notre vote
aujourd'hui nous invite à proroger le
mandat des membres du conseil économique
social et environnemental
jusqu'au 30 septembre 2010 au plus tard
ce délai doit permettre de mener à son
terme une réflexion de fond sur la
réforme de cette institution
j'ai eu l'occasion de le souligner dans
mon récent rapport d'information sur le
conseil comme rapporteur spécial de
notre commission des finances pour le
budget du csa et c'est à ce titre la
crise intervient aujourd'hui dans la
discussion générale la réforme
constitutionnelle opérée par la loi
constitutionnelle de modernisation des
institutions de la vème république
du 23 juillet 2008 n'en porte pas en
effet n'en portent en effet pas
seulement un changement de dénomination
du conseil devenu conseil économique
social et environnemental
mais elle commande de façon beaucoup
plus ambitieuse de repenser la place
même du cee ce au sein de notre paysage
institutionnel et d'adapter
l'organisation ainsi que le
fonctionnement de cette institution
ne nous y trompons pas la période qui
s'engage aujourd'hui est une période
charnière pour le cs le défi à relever
dans les mois à venir ne relève
nullement du simple formalisme juridique
il ne s'agit ni plus ni moins de
façonner le visage du conseil pour le
futur l'enjeu est double à la fois
améliorer la représentativité de
l'institution et d'autre part
perfectionner son fonctionnement à
moyens budgétaires constants la
spécificité du crs 1 réside dans sa
capacité à offrir un lieu privilégié de
débats et des échanges entre les
différentes composantes de la société
française
de ce point de vue la composition du
concept du cs 1 qui n'a que très peu
évolué depuis 1958
est la plus controversée dans un rapport
publié en janvier dernier monsieur
dominique jean chertier lui même membre
du conseil a d'ailleurs contribué à
ouvrir la réflexion trois scénarii sont
suggérées dans son rapport allant du
simple ajustement périodique de la
composition du conseil jusqu'à une
assemblée des corps intermédiaires en
passant par une assemblée des experts de
la société civile comme l'ont souligné
tout à l'heure notre rapporteur
jean-pierre vial et comme la développer
notre collègue richard yung s'il n'est
pas encore temps de trancher entre ces
différentes options
mais déjà un certain nombre
d'intervenants avant moi on pose est
dépressif voire d'imaginer d'autres
options
un impératif doit néanmoins être rappelé
cette réforme devra s'opérer à moyens
constants est restée neutre s'agissant
de son impact budgétaire
c'est en tout cas le souci qu en tant
que rapporteur spécial je voulais
signaler ici le nombre a été fixé à 233
membres c'est à dire identique à celui
qui est actuellement
ceci en similitudes complète avec la
fixation par cette loi constitutionnelle
de juillet 2008 en confort et en
corrélation avec ce qui a été fait pour
le nombre de membres du sénat et pour le
nombre de membres de l'assemblée
nationale je tiens à cet égard a
souligné que cet objectif de rester à
moyens constants et est un objectif
totalement partagée par l'actuel
président du csa monsieur jacques
dermagne en tant que rapporteur spécial
de la mission conseil et contrôle de
l'état dont dépendent les crédits du cv
je ne peux que me féliciter de cette
sagesse budgétaire et de ce souci de
prendre le virage de la réforme sans
dérapage financier
cette politique volontariste visant à
tenir la dépense s'inscrit d'ailleurs
dans la continuité des efforts
budgétaires mises en oeuvre par cette
institution telle que je peux en
témoigner depuis cinq ans ou jeu
je présente ici devant notre notre sénat
le budget du chef du cns outre les
dépenses de fonctionnement courant liées
aux changements de l'institution il
conviendra donc d'absorber à budget
constant
un certain nombre de coups difficiles à
évoluer dans l'immédiat mais des coups
certains je pense notamment à ceux
induits par le droit de saisine
parlementaire mais surtout à ceux
résultant du non vous droit de siffler
deux pétitions citoyennes nouveau droit
qui risque d'occasionner des coûts
importants du gestion d'autre part avec
le rajeunissement nécessaire du conseil
je dis bien nécessaire et naturellement
je suis d'accord sur cet objectif
mais s'il faudra aussi prendre en compte
de facto le coût supplémentaire pour la
caisse de retraite
il faudra donc trouver des économies par
ailleurs le rapport chartier de janvier
dernier et celui que j'ai présentées ici
au mois de mai donne quelques pistes en
ce sens et je souhaite que nous ayons
des propositions du gouvernement
madame la ministre
le csa se trouve aujourd'hui à la
croisée des chemins il a été trop
longtemps cantonné dans un anonymat
relatif il aujourd'hui il se voit offert
une opportunité inédite d'affirmer
encore un peu plus et d'affermir encore
un peu mieux son statut de troisième
assemblée constitutionnelle
en ce sens la mise en oeuvre de la loi
du 23 juillet 2008 représente bien pour
lui une chance à saisir dans les mois à
venir sur cette voie tout ne dépendra
toutefois pas que de lui
la volonté politique exprimée en
particulier par le parlement et par
l'autre sénat jouera un rôle éminent
dans l'évolution et l'influencent du
conseil
je tiens à cet égard a souligné à
l'ensemble de nos collègues et en guise
de conclusion
tout l'intérêt de notre assemblée a tiré
le plus largement possible profit des
possibilités de consultation du csa qui
lui sont désormais offertes le dialogue
entre notre sénat et le conseil a
toujours été fructueux mais uniquement
commission il ne tient qu'à nous de
l'enrichir encore plus dans les années à
venir au plus grand bénéfice des deux
des deux institutions et surtout de
l'intérêt général qui nous est cher je
suis love tout à fait favorable à ce
projet de loi je vous remercie de votre
attention vous remercie vraiment chers
collègues la discussion générale est
close nous passons à la discussion de
l'article unique
il n'ya pas d'amendement vous souhaitiez
pardon voulait dire un bon madame la
même avec grand plaisir
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs sénateurs normands
se trouvent interpellés sur un certain
nombre de sujets je vois d'abord
remercier l'ensemble des orateurs qui se
sont exprimés et salué le climat très
consensuel dans lequel se déroule cette
discussion et j'espère que tous auront à
coeur et je n'en doute pas de trouver le
même esprit consensuel à l'occasion de
l'examen du projet de loi organique
en effet aujourd'hui ce n'est que la
prolongation du mandat et un certain
nombre de questions qui ont été
soulevées ne pourront trouver réponse
qu'à ce moment là donc je vais me
contenter de de reprendre quelques
points sur lequel je peux d'ores et déjà
apporté des éclairages
plusieurs sénateurs est notamment
président vial
on soulevait je crois le problème de la
représentation des cultes je vous
confirme ce qu' henri de raincourt a
déjà dû indiquer à l'assemblée nationale
une représentation des cultes ne sera
pas proposée dans la loi organique
l'ouverture vers les grands courants de
pensée n'implique pas nécessairement une
représentation institutionnelle et de
toute façon il est possible et il est
évident que cela devra être fait de
recueillir et de prendre en
considération les positions et les idées
développées par l'ensemble des cultes et
des mouvements de pensée à l'occasion
des saisines qui porterait à la messe
copier et a évoqué avec madame ça si la
féminisation du conseil économique et
social et je crois aussi qu'au moment de
mon arrivée
ça faisait vue propos de monsieur ue le
président de la république a affirmé la
nécessité de faire progresser la parité
dans la représentation du cee est ce
c'est un objectif essentiel et c'est
évident pour que le ce est ce soit
pleinement en adéquation avec la société
civile pour qu'ils puissent répondre
grandes évolutions de la société
parce que c'est quand même la moitié
d'humanité ça c'est moi qui rajoute donc
le projet de loi organique relatif à la
composition du cef devra donc poursuivre
et renforcer sa féminisation
c'est un objectif que nous pouvons tous
et tout partager et ainsi qu'a pu le
suggérer madame escoffier le
renouvellement du conseil pourrait aussi
impliquer quelques innovations comme la
diminution l'âge minimum pour siéger ce
qu'ils entreraient dans l'objectif
repris par plusieurs parmi vous de
rajeunissement et la limitation du
nombre de mandats ne se s'il va être à
nouveau discutée par votre assemblée
un petit mot sur la représentation des
français de l'étranger
c'est vrai que c'est un sujet qui devra
être examinée à miner la réflexion doit
être engagée comme dans tous les autres
groupes
et pour ce groupe il faut souligner que
le contexte a changé puisque le
président la république a souhaité
offrir une plus grande représentation
français de l'étranger
avec au delà la représentation
sénatoriales une représentation à
l'occasion des prochaines élections
législatives donc l'heure n'est pas
encore aux réponses sur cette question
mais mais mais manifestement le contexte
a changé enfin sur la question qui a été
soulevée par madame assassi de l'
équilibre entre représentation des
employeurs et représentation des
salariés
je crois qu'en irak où il a rappelé
aussi dans son discours est important
pour gouvernement que les grands
équilibres puisse être au sein du
conseil puisse être conservé et tout
particulièrement les équilibres entre
les représentants des employeurs et les
représentants des salariés qui devra
être préservé je le redis ici
merci monsieur le président je vous
remercie madame la mini ça j sans
explication de vote monsieur blanc mais
avec grand plaisir également zidor je
voudrais quand même exprimé conseil
économique et social jours à volonté et
la décision du groupe ump de voter
bien sûr cette ce texte félicité le
rapporteur nous réjouir du consensus et
indiqué qu' il apparaît comme sage en
face de ce qui est quand même une
évolution importante du conseil
économique et social environnemental
désormais de prendre un peu de temps
pour bien réussir ce qui est une réforme
importante puisque ce conseil va
s'adapter aux évolutions le
développement durable l'exigence de
parité
l'évolution du monde social et
économique et il faudra trouver la
formule idéale puisque ça se fait à
moyens constants financiers et surtout
dans le nombre
or modifier des compositions c'est très
facile d'en parler et puis quand on
arrive pour faire rentrer
les objectifs des uns et des autres sans
augmenter le nombre de membres c'est
vrai que c'est quand même un exercice
sans doute difficile et parfois un peu
périlleux donc que gouvernement prenne
un peu de temps pour mettre en place
cette réforme
quoi de plus étonnant et il a pris la
solution de sagesse car ça aurait été
sans doute un peu difficile de renault
mais pour peu de temps
ou alors que là c'est donc nous
semble-t-il une solution que nous
approuvons voilà pourquoi nous voterons
ce texte ont félicité encore le
rapporteur je remercie chez le collègue
monsieur del picchia comme explication
de vote vous signale que nous avons
ensuite un très long texte non et qu'il
y aura des personnes qui assisteront à
cette nuit peu énorme chérif les 10
bon ça marche je prendrai la parole
lorsque l'on parlera vraiment de la loi
organique qui reconstitue le conseil
économique social et environnemental je
voulais répondre à mon collègue monsieur
lyon que j'apprécie ce consensus
aujourd'hui dans cette salle oms qui
concerne sa proposition de les faire
nommer les représentants des français
l'étranger par les associations là je
m'y opposerai parce qu'il y ait une
assemblée élue au suffrage universel
direct des français de l'étranger à
laquelle siègent aussi laisser la terre
est bien tous les députés et je crois
que ce sera plutôt à l'assemblée de le
faire on en parlera lors de cette loi
merci monsieur le président merci chers
collègues s'agissant d'un projet de
l'organique
mes chers collègues je vais mettre voir
l'article unique constituant l'ensemble
de ce projet il n'ya plus d'explications
de vote et donc je vais mettre voir
l'article unique en application de
l'article 59 du règlement de scrutin
public est de droit
il va être procédé dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront secrétaires un bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
mettront un bulletin bleu
ceux qui souhaitent s'abstenir au métro
un bulletin rouge le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
c'est fait ces prêts le scrutin est
ouvert
à
plus personne ne demande à voter à voter
voter ah bon le scrutin est clos
j'invite madame et messieurs les
secrétaires a procédé au dépouillement
du scrutin
voilà
ok
il y en a
g
les résultats du scrutin numéro 200 sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi organique
prorogeant le mandat des membres du
conseil économique social et
environnemental nombre de votants 338
nombre de suffrages exprimés 338
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
cent soixante dix pour l'adoption 3,138
contre 0 lors du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
relative à la lutte contre la fracture
numérique présentée par monsieur xavier
pintât dans la discussion générale la
parole est à monsieur xavier pintât
auteur de la proposition de loi
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je voudrais tout d'abord vous remercier
d'avoir accepté d'inscrire à l'ordre du
jour des travaux du sénat
le très important dossier de
l'aménagement numérique de notre
territoire national parmi les nombreux
défis auxquels nous sommes aujourd'hui
confrontés le déploiement des moyens
d'accès à l'internet à très haut débit
figure en bonne place
nombreux sont ceux qui voient l'un des
principaux piliers de l'après crise tant
les effets de son déploiement seront
profonds multiples dans pratiquement
tous les domaines le développement du
très haut débit va en effet amené de
profonds bouleversements dans la façon
de s'informer de se former de travail et
de communiquer il en sera ainsi avec la
visioconférence et le télétravail
invitant des transports de personnes
coûteux en temps et en énergie
je rappelle d'ailleurs que le
télétravail concerne déjà 40% des
salariés au japon mais seulement 10 %
qu'en france il en ira de même pour
l'enseignement
le très haut débit offrant la capacité
inédite de se relier au monde dans des
conditions d'ergonomie et de rapidité
inégalée mettant à disposition de
nouveaux tableaux numériques interactifs
l'accès au très haut débit touchera
également le domaine de la santé avec la
possibilité d'interventions
chirurgicales à distance l'accès aux
services publics a lieu du visuel à la
domotique en sera métamorphosé
contribuant de manière décisive au
désenclavement des territoires
la puissance et la rapidité des travaux
scientifiques et d'ingénierie seront
accrus de manière fantastique
le plan de développement de l'économie
numérique du gouvernement madame la
ministre a bien un perte auriez le vaste
éventail d applications des technologies
de communication numérique
c'est en réalité l'ensemble du
fonctionnement économique social
administratives culturelles de notre
pays qui pourra bénéficier du saut
technologique se sont technologique va
constituer le très haut débit par
rapport aux réseaux à haut débit actuel
dont les limites de capacité
constitueront très rapidement des
goulets d'étranglement inacceptable
l'ambition portée par le plan france
numérique 2012 de faire de la france
l'un des leaders en matière de très haut
débit est grande et incontournable nous
parlons donc ce soir d'un grand chantier
national et ce débat est pour moi
l'occasion de vous remercier madame la
ministre
devon investissement personnel sur ce
dossier pour lequel vous marquez votre
ferme intention de fédérer avec
intelligence tous les acteurs opérateurs
pouvoirs publics et bien sûr les
collectivités territoriales mes
remerciements vont également au
président de notre commission de
l'économie du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire jean paul
emorine et à son vice président pierre
hérisson qui a parfaitement président et
nos débats je les remercie pour leur
expertise et leur design discernement je
vais également salué le travail
considérable accompli et dans un délai
record par bruno retailleau le
rapporteur de cette proposition de loi
et remercie aussi l'ensemble de mes
collègues qui ont soutenu cette
proposition le groupe ump son président
gérard longuet avec une mention spéciale
je l'aperçois pour jacques plan qui a
été le premier à soutenir cette
initiative
sans oublier bien sûr nos collègues
issus d'autres groupes en particulier
nathalie goulet et aymeri de montesquiou
l'enjeu du déploiement des réseaux de
communications électroniques à très haut
débit est telle que nous devons tout
faire pour permettre à l'ensemble mon
territoire d'en bénéficier dans un délai
raisonnable le très haut débit va faire
figure comme l'électricité de service
vital rendant insupportable toute
fracture territoriale en ce domaine nos
entreprises vont pouvoir faire le choix
de s'implanter dans
villes petites et moyennes et même en
milieu rural en y bénéficier d'accès
efficient et compétitif à internet
abolissant quelque sorte que les
distances géographiques et permettant de
conjuguer la qualité de vie avec la
performance économique
une grosse entreprise installée à paris
souhaitera le ses sous traitants
disposent d'un accès à très haut débit
pour être plus efficace et réactif or la
france est actuellement au début
seulement de ce déploiement
on ne compte en effet que 180 mille
abonnés au très haut débit pour 18
millions d'abonnés haut débit
de plus ces prises très haut débit ne
concerne que les grandes zones urbaines
dans lesquelles sont présentes plusieurs
opérateurs et pour lesquels la question
pertinente et celle des modalités du
déploiement vertical
c'est à dire du câblage des immeubles
dans des conditions respectueuses de
l'intérêt des résidents et du droit à la
concurrence
la desserte en réseau de communications
électroniques en très haut débit des
zones moins denses et d'un ressort bien
différent ces zones sont confrontés à la
contrainte propre à tous les réseaux
filaires celle des sur longueur abonnés
qui caractérise les territoires à faible
densité blocs démographique et qui en
compromettre la rentabilité pour les
investisseurs pour rendre possible la
réalisation des centaines de milliers de
kilomètres de fibres que suppose le
maillage notre territoire
cette contrainte devraient être levés
cela passe par une volonté politique
très semblable à celle qui a permis à
partir des années 30 d'irriguer
l'ensemble de notre pays en énergie
électrique grâce à l'implication des
collectivités responsables de la
distribution d'électricité et grâce à
l'appui du dispositif de péréquation
financière que constitue le fonds
d'amortissement des charges
d'électrification face et mes chers
collègues
je vous propose dans cet objectif un
dispositif a trois composantes
la première concerne l'indispensable
rationalisation et la mise en cohérence
du déploiement de la fibre optique
ce déploiement nous le savons sur une
opération coûteuse mais il est toutefois
possible de maîtriser ses coûts en
organisant et en favorisant le partage
des infrastructures entre réseaux de
communications électroniques mais aussi
avec d'autres réseaux publics au premier
rang desquels bien sûr la distribution
d'électricité dont le partenariat avec
le secteur des télécommunications
résulte structurellement temps de
l'histoire que de la géographie et de la
technique
et dans cette perspective proposé
l'élaboration de schémas directeurs
territoriaux d'aménagement numérique
ces schémas feront tout d'abord
l'inventaire de l'existant termes
d'infrastructures et de réseaux en haut
et en très haut débit de façon à définir
les besoins prioritaires des schémas ont
ensuite pour objectif de définir des
orientations à ce qui concerne le
développement sur le territoire concerné
des réseaux de communications
électroniques en très haut débit
il me semble important s'agissant des
investissements nouveaux a programmé de
faire très clairement du haut débit du
très haut débit
la priorité absolue consentir des moyens
importants pour le développement de la
desserte sur des débits de type adsl
reviendrait à nous conduire à distraire
une partie substantielle de nos
financements sur les ouvrages qui
deviendront rapidement technologiquement
obsolète et devront donc être remplacées
sans doute avant même d'avoir été
amortis en totalité par les technologies
du très haut débit qui seul apparaissent
pérenne à l'heure actuelle la deuxième
composante concerne le portage
territoria de l'élaboration des schémas
si nous voulons favoriser ne dessert que
satisfaisante des zones grises et des
zones blanches du très haut débit
il importe nous donner une vision
suffisamment large des territoires
permettant de mettre en lumière des
logiques de solidarité territoriale
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vais
proposer de retenir comme périmètres
l'élaboration de chacun des schémas une
aire géographique correspondant au moins
à celle de département ou un ensemble
démographique cohérent cela induit que
le schéma soit élaborée par une personne
publique de taille suffisante afin de
tenir compte de la compétence
concurrente des divers niveaux de
collectivités locales et de groupements
pour exercer les attributions définies
en matière de communications
électroniques par le code général des
collectivités territoriales
votre commission propose que les
syndicats mixtes qui permettent de
regrouper des collectivités de nature
très différente mais aussi les
départements mais aussi les régions en
tant que tel puisse assurer
l'élaboration du schéma ce qui me semble
une solution de sagesse permettant de
s'adapter à la diversité des approches
locales
la troisième composante me paraît
fondamental il s'agit de la mise en
place d'un fonds d'aménagement numérique
des territoires destinés à contribuer au
financement de certains travaux de
réalisation des ouvrages prévus par les
schémas directeurs
l'objectif est ici de permettre l'accès
de l'ensemble de la population aux
communications électroniques à très haut
débit à un coût raisonnable
je remercie la commission des précisions
complément qu'elle a porté sur ce point
en particulier en ce qui concerne le
rôle du régulateur pour la détermination
des zones éligibles aux aides du fonds
la robustesse juridique de ce fonds va
certainement être amélioré au bénéfice
de l'ensemble des secteurs géographiques
et les populations dont la desserte sera
il faut il faut y insister impossible
sans un tel dispositif
je souhaite que celui ci puissent
rapidement bénéficier de sa première
notation financière et le lancement du
grand emprunt national en donnera
peut-être madame la ministre
l'opportunité de façon à retarder le
déploiement de la fibre optique
au delà des zones denses ou très dense
mes chers collègues
vous avez souhaité inséré par ailleurs
dans la proposition de loi une
disposition relative à l'obligation pour
chaque collège
chers collègues je vous prie de
m'excuser je vous interromps un instant
car je souhaite informer au nom du
président du sénat que pour la première
fois sous la vème république de senna
vient à l'instant précis de dépasser les
1000 heures de séance depuis l'ouverture
de la session ordinaire le 1er octobre
je vous remercie chers collègues et je
vous prie de m'excuser de vous avoir
interrompu mais nous avons considéré que
c'était un moment solennel dont vous
pouvez bénéficier
je suis très honoré je donne ma parole
mais sa collègue donc vous avez souhaité
inséré par ailleurs dans la proposition
de loi une disposition relative à
l'obligation pour un maître d'ouvragé au
vent une tranchée d accueillir des
infrastructures de communications
électroniques à la demande d'une
collectivité territoriale d'un
groupement de collectivités
cela me semble très opportun à condition
de préciser que cela doit se faire avec
le souci de la cohérence entre réseaux
d'initiative publique puisque le maître
d ouvrage de la tranchée peut être lui
même une collectivité et vous présente
tel moment venu un amendement en ce sens
madame la ministre d'importantes
dispositions relatives à la couverture
télévisuelle des territoires dans le
cadre du basculement vers la télévision
numérique terrestre ont également été
ajoutées au texte
dans le cas des travaux de notre
commission ces dispositions ne semble
avoir d'autant plus leur place dans un
texte relatif aux communications
électroniques en très haut débit
conax est performant internet fait
partie des dispositifs alternatifs
susceptible de pallier l'insuffisance de
la couverture de certains territoire par
la tnt
il veut parer aux importants en tout
état de cause que la couverture des
coûts afférents au traitement des zones
dont monum eric soit assurée de façon à
ce que ni les abonnés ni les
collectivités ne soient pénalisés par
ces évolutions
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
l'aménagement numérique en très haut
débit de notre territoire national est
un défi exaltant enthousiasme que nous
sommes nombreux à partager dans ce
domaine aura raison j'en suis certain
des difficultés à résoudre et je me
réjouis que notre débat d'aujourd'hui
plus y concourir
je vous remercie notre attention
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole et à monsieur bruno retailleau
rapporteur de la commission de
l'économie du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire
monsieur le président madame monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la révolution numérique qui s'accélère
sous nos yeux a deux caractéristiques
elle est d'abord planétaire au sens que
elle contribue à l'aplatissement de
notre monde comme aurait dit thomas
friedman
elle est aussi dans un autre sens
mondiale est planétaire
on l'a vu récemment avec le rôle qu'a
joué à internet dans l'élection
américaine
on le voit et on l'a vu aussi
malheureusement dans des événements
beaucoup plus grave en iran avec le rôle
qu internet à jouer dans la diffusion de
l'information
elle a une autre caractéristique c'est
qu'il s'agit pas simplement pour cette
révolution numérique d'une simple
mutation technologique mais il s'agit
d'une rupture radicale qui impacte
l'ensemble qui transforme l'ensemble des
activités humaines
xavier pintât vient à juste titre
d'ailleurs d'énumérer un certain nombre
de services
mais notre façon de communiquer de
travailler demain de nous former de nous
soigner etc etc sont impactés bien
entendu par cette révolution numérique
de même qu'elle transforme nos systèmes
de production notre système économique
dans le plan france numérique 2012
il y avait un objectif qui figurait de
30% en termes de contribution à la
croissance mondiale à l'horizon 2015 ce
qui est parfaitement considérable et je
crois que au moment où la france
traverse une crise économique profonde
où elle cherche un nouveau modèle de
croissance je pense madame le ministre
que nous partageons cette conviction
cette certitude même que l'économie
numérique est pour demain un des leviers
très importants de ce nouveau modèle de
croissance qui permettra de libérer des
énergies et surtout de créer de la
valeur de créer de nombreux emplois
notre pays a su correctement négocié la
première étape de la révolution
numérique avec le haut débit avec un peu
plus 18 millions de foyers connectés
nous avons l'un des taux de pénétration
les meilleurs d'europe et surtout nous
avons quelques offres les meilleurs au
monde en termes par exemple de
télévision par adsl ou
de téléphone sur ip en revanche on ne
peut pas s'en satisfaire parce que très
vite cette étape est dépassé et on voit
poindre une nouvelle étape qui s'annonce
avec le très haut débit
tout simplement parce que les nouveaux
usages sont de plus en plus
consommateurs en débit ya de plus en
plus d'interactivité
il ya de plus en plus de consommation
d'image demain nous serons dans la
réalité augmentée dans la réalité
virtuelle
il faudra des débits de plus en plus
important ce qui fait que nos vieux
réseaux seront très vite obsolète et
qu'il faut penser à la nouvelle reine
nouvelle génération de réseaux pour le
21e siècle avec la fibre optique bien
entendu
et de ce point de vue là notre pays sans
doute a des atouts mais il a aussi des
fragilités
il a une fragilité monsieur le ministre
mercier qui est que la france est sans
doute eu un des pays au monde où la
ruralité la plus importante
en tout cas en europe nous sommes le
grand pays de la ruralité 50% de la
population française vit dans des
communes de moins de 10000 habitants la
part de ruralité au sens où on l'entend
général ces 31 % de la population mais
c'est plus de 70% du territoire et donc
on ne peut pas à terme les c1 un
territoire aussi important sur le bord
de la route pour cette révolution qui
s'annonce et qui sera absolument capital
le risque d'une france à deux vitesses
avec un internet des villes et un
internet deschamps est une menace qui
est extrêmement importante c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense que la
proposition de loi de xavier pintât est
la bienvenue
elle est la bienvenue parce qu'elle
tombe au bon moment au moment où on
réfléchit au déploiement de ces nouveaux
réseaux
elle tombe aussi au bon moment parce que
elle rappelle que le très haut débit
c'est l'infrastructure essentielle de la
société de l'information de demain je ne
reviens pas sur les dispositifs jean
rappelle peut-être deux qui me semble
important en matière de planification
avec les schémas d'aménagement numérique
à l'échelle minimum du territoire
départemental pour qu'il y ait une
péréquation entre des zones qui seront
des zones plus denses et des hommes qui
sont moins denses le deuxième dispositif
avec un fonds qui signifie que l'état
mais j'y reviendrais tout à l'heure ne
pourra pas se désintéresser
financièrement budgétairement du
déploiement du très haut débit dans
notre pays ça paraît évident alors notre
commission a travaillé dans des délais
très courts merci xavier pintât de
l'avoir rappelé mais nous avons tenu à
conserver l'esprit de la proposition de
loi tout en l'enrichissant avec deux
constats le premier constat c'est qu'il
ya déjà une fracture numérique y compris
avec le haut débit et qu'il faut aussi
de la réduire et le deuxième constat
bien sûr avec le très haut débit et la
fibre il faut l'anticiper il faut
prévenir l'apparition d'une nouvelle
fracture numérique d'abord la réduction
d'une fracture qui est pas la fracture
de demain mais qui est la fracture
d'aujourd'hui il y a trois sujets mes
chers collègues la tnt
la montée en débit et enfin l'outre-mer
vous venez de suivre une partie de la
discussion générale du projet de loi
visant à réduire la fracture numérique
tout